hey guys won't make the new rockstars
I'm Sam basher and today I'm talking
about one of the more divisive films of
the MCU Iron Man 3 while this movie does
have a fairly decent Rotten Tomatoes
score fans are still pretty split on it
for me my opinion didn't change them
there you watch I actually really enjoy
this film my opinion doesn't matter
right now I'm here just to deliver you
guys those juicy Easter eggs
he's your spoiler warning for comic book
Easter eggs for Iron Man I'm a movie
easter egg MCU Easter eggs anyways let's
get started with comic book Easter eggs
those are me favorite days opening in
Bern Switzerland we meet one of the main
characters from the Iron Man storyline
extremists in the comics which most of
this movie is based on I'm talking about
Rebecca Hall's Maya Hansen character she
appeared in Iron Man vol 4 number 1 in
January 2005 and she was created by
Warren Ellis which name does come up
later in this movie but more on that a
second also it's true in this movie and
in the comics that she is the creator of
extremists hard we then bump into ho
yinsen yeah he made a return from Iron
Man 1 if you guys remember that line
from the first Iron Man movie he
mentions running into Tony Stark a few
years earlier that seemed just like a
throwaway line but it does pay off in
the third and final solo Ironman film
also there's a deeper cut reference to
yinsen later on in this movie but I'll
get back to that in just a second we
then meet dr. Wu who's played by GE Wong
who actually plays a bigger role later
on in this movie but he was created
originally for this film but was later
introduced into the amazing spider-man
comics and also his name is reference to
the Steely Dan song of the same name
then moving forward we bump into our
main antagonist of the film Aldrich
Killian played by guy Pierce I'm a big
guy Pierce fan he's great Aldrich
Killian does have a pretty small role in
the comic specifically Iron Man vol 4
number 1 which came out in July 2005 but
most of his origin was created for this
film he too popped up in the extremest
storyline but in this film he was
adapted to be the creator of aim now
originally aim was a scientific arm of
Hydra in the comics which would
eventually break off and they get their
own little suits here's a little flash
room they come in yellow blue and red
now while aim is usually a villain too
many Marvel characters they're currently
a branch of the Avengers which i think
is a very interesting storyline that
will never happen in the movies but hey
still fun we then move forward a Hanson
showing Tony her extremities basically
the same extremis that we see in the
comics we then run into one of the main
stars of this movie the mark 42 armor
now it is a little bit different from
the design
that is in the comics which had show up
a little bit after this film but mark 42
could be a nod to Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy the answer 42 being the
answer to all life in the universe and
everything or could be a mentioned to
the 40 second idea that Tony Stark Reed
Richards and the rest of his team were
able to come up with which was putting a
prison in the negative zone to house
super-powered people next we meet one of
Iron Man's greatest foes the foe that's
been teased for three films now the
Mandarin he first appeared in tales of
suspense number 50 in February 1964 now
Mandarin in this film is completely
different from the one in the comics for
a very good reason now a lot of fans
aren't happy with this twist in the film
but Marvel did have to kind of maneuver
their way around a lot of racist
stereotypes so I think they did the best
they could there are some alternatives
I'd like to hear your pitches in the
comments down below or hit me up on
Twitter with them now I have mentioned
this before but in the original Iron Man
film he was supposed to be the main
antagonist but director Jon Favreau
chose to hold off on him and kind of
tease him throughout the series but
eventually that all backfired so they
just threw that all out also worth
mentioning in the trailer for Iron Man 3
we see Mandarin take off his hood and we
see that he has a neck tattoo of the
Captain America shield but with a very
important difference I know it's a
little hard to see but if you noticed
the star in the middle of the shield has
been replaced with the Anarchy a symbol
next we run into Don Cheadle playing
James Rhodes aka war machine aka the
iron patriot who first appeared in Dark
Avengers number 1 in March of 2009 so
relatively a new design now originally
the comics the iron patriot was actually
Norman Osborn the Green Goblin yes how
cool is that now in the comics Norman
Osborn was seen as a hero because he was
the one who stopped the secret invasion
event and then he eventually led a evil
version of The Avengers specifically and
this suit was supposed to be you know a
reflection of Iron Man and Captain
America put into one now he didn't have
that armor for very long but eventually
a new he rode by the name of Tony Howe
took up the iron patriot mantle who in
the comics is the daughter of yinsen
very cool moving forward to a happy and
peper hanging out together you hear him
talk to one of the secretaries calling
her Bambi we actually saw Bambi in Iron
Man 2 speaking of small-time characters
we run into Erik Sivan in this same
Lobby qin being Killians main security
guy he actually appeared in Marvel
Comics presents numbers 26 in August
1989 and he is a completely different
comic book counterpart besides both
being from the military
in the same name they're totally
different and speaking of villains that
are totally different outside of the
Chinese Theatre we meet Taggert but in
the comics there's a Taggert that
spelled t AG ger T instead of AR T this
character actually popped up in Iron Man
number 230 in May of 1989 but once again
he's very different from his comic book
counterpart actually Taggart in the
comics is firepower
he's an armored rival to Iron Man and
they fought several times but he has no
ties the the extremis story but we did
get a mention of him there moving
forward to Antonius investigating the
Mandarin we seen image of a dragon in
his hologram which could be a not too
something later in the film or this is
possibly a quickie not to think fang
foom one of the classic Marvel foes that
is mentioned many times in the Iron Man
films we even saw him on a movie poster
in the first movie then moving forward
to the assault on Tony's house we see
the Iron Man armor protect Pepper this
is actually a really fun nod to the
rescue armor that pepper wore for some
time in the comics actually if you're
reading Iron Man right now she wears it
sometimes grey then moving forward again
to our time in Tennessee we run into
Ellen brand to one of the small-time
baddies in this film but actually she
plays a pretty significant role in
another Marvel heroes backstory the Man
Thing to give a quick backstory in the
origins of Man Thing we meet Ted Sallis
a scientist who created a super soldier
like serum formula what have you and
after creating said formula he's hunted
down by aim and is actually betrayed by
his wife Ellen Brandt and as a way to
escape he injects himself with that
formula but things go wrong and he turns
into this they're gross but he does
obtain a very special power to burn
people who touch him who are also
feeling fear at the same time so he does
end up burning his wife on the face and
he we see that Ellen Brant in this movie
has a burn on her face could this be a
nod to Man Thing which is a lil nod also
fontaine the Ted Sallis formula is based
on a plant research project and the
extremis formula is also based on plants
in this film but moving forward to
Killians two big dragon tattoos we see
near the end of the film there is some
talk that this could be a nod to fing
Fang Foom as well but hey it's worth
mentioning
weirdly guys that's as many comic book
tie-ins as I could find there are but 10
of MCU tie-ins so let's talk about those
right up front we hear Tony talking to
someone a famous man once said we create
our own demons which we identify at the
very end of the fan but more on that in
a short second in that same opening
scene of this movie we see footage of
Iron Man's armor being blown up we see
the mark 5 and very
when we see the six as well as the seven
and the eight which we both saw in the
Avengers films and then moving forward
we see the Marvel title once again the
awesome comic book clip my favorite one
as well as a paramount title which is
one of the last films at Paramount was
able to distribute for Marvel also
coming back to Maya Hansen's character
for just a second she was actually
originally supposed to be the main
villain of this film but that was
eventually removed because Marvel didn't
think that a female villains toys would
sell sacks I'm going to be honest moving
forward we get a quick 10 rings logo the
ten rings being the terrorist group that
has been in each Iron Man film and
here's their leader the Mandarin played
by Ben Kingsley where he talked about
him but moving forward to president
Ellis present Alice actually isn't in
the comics but his name is a nod to the
man who created the extremis storyline
Warren Ellis he writes some fantastic
comics if you're a fan of the Punisher
and you want to read an extremely
violent and gritty story check out
Punisher max also just wanna point out
the iron Patriot armor is rebranded by
aim and in Iron Man 2 the war machine
armor was rebranded by hammer and that
didn't go so well
also in this movie the aim rebrand gets
hacked by aim if you have Tony just work
on your armor from now on hey Rhodey
moving on to one of the main Mandarin
broadcasts that we see being filmed we
get a nod to Roxxon Oil Company one of
the biggest organizations in Marvel
Comics which has appeared in every Iron
Man film up until now in the first film
you saw him in the background in the
second film eat they had one of the cars
in the Formula One race moving forward
again we're moving pretty quick through
this film to when Killian has Tony Stark
all tied up he references the war in a
very cool way check it out ever since
that big dude with a hammer fell out of
the sky subtlety's kind of had its day
moving forward again here's a funny
Easter Egg for Iron Man 2 the ponytail
Express captor is actually the same
prisoner that was used to be switched
out for Ivan Vanko somehow he survived
and they ended up over here now here's
the part you're most excited about let's
start identifying some of the Iron Man
armor that shows up in the final battle
first up we see the Iron Man mark 17
heartbreaker which is the first to
appear in that aerial lineup very cool
then we get the Iron Man mark 37 aka the
hammer head because this is actually an
aquatic suit we then get the Iron Man
mark 41 bones design which is the black
and gold armor which for me is my
favorite design so I'm not really sure
why he made the 42 I get that it builds
itself so it's more practical but that
design is awesome then we meet the proto
Hulkbuster suit mark 38 aka Igor named
after the Hunchback from you know
Frankenstein then there's the Iron Man
mark 35 red snap
which has got the Reg big claw thing
then there's the mark 33 nicknamed
silver Centurion armor which is really
similar to the suitcase armor in Iron
Man 2 which I thought was supposed to be
a nod to the silver Centurion but hey
I'm happy if we got to then I wanted to
point out that the armor that picks up
Rhodey is actually the mark 17 and then
we see the mark 25 aka the striker
that's wrong with this jackhammers that
hits the two extremis soldiers and we
see stark jump into the mark 22 aka the
hot rod but that's destroyed pretty
quick after that one also it's worth
mentioning just to take a break for a
second that when Killian gets his arm
cut off this actually is a theme that is
repeated quite often in Phase two which
I will talk about more in upcoming films
but moving back to the armors we see the
Iron Man mark 16 aka the nightclub suit
which is described as a stealth suit and
then we get the Iron Man mark 40 suit
aka the shotgun which ejects Tony pretty
quick and then finally Tony jumps into
the mark 15 sneaky suit but that one
gets destroyed pretty quick upon landing
and then one of the last suits were able
to see is actually the one that targets
Pepper for having the extremest in her
system that's the mark 8 which she's
able to bring down in a really cool
badass move whoo-hoo those are all the
armors I was able identify after that
they just start blowing up and another
shout-out to dr. Wu which we see at the
very end he's removing the shrapnel from
Tony's heart but finally we're able to
figure out who Tony is narrating this
entire movie - and it's - his friend
Bruce Banner aka the Hulk
but finally guys before I leave you
let's discuss some quick pop-culture
references in this movie the opening
song definitely means a nod it's blue by
Eiffel 65 who I'm a big fan of that song
here's a clip next up I just wanted to
mention that Mya was originally going to
be played by Jessica Chastain but she
had to drop out of the film that would
have been kind of cool for a second also
fun nod to John Travolta's character in
Pulp Fiction Jon Favreau's happy hook
and look in the 90s it's supposed to be
a nod to that they're moving forward -
when Tony starts trying on the mark 42
suit you hear jingle bells playing in
the background which is one of many nods
that this is a Christmas film which is
actually goes into the theme of shamed
likes movies up until now like The Last
Boy Scout and Kiss Kiss Bang Bang they
usually take place during the Christmas
season you're stark mentioned that this
kid looks like the kid from a Christmas
story which is pretty fun because the
kid who did play that kid in a Christmas
story was in the first Iron Man film
Peter Billingsley he played this really
tiny role right here fun nod during the
Chinese Theater fight we actually see
for just a second Robert Downey jr.
'he's handprint it's really hard to see
but it is there i think it's a pretty
fun nod to the actor then there's
actually a really good reference to the
west
world movie we hear during this scene
yes Ivan's
eyes look a lot like how the robots
androids looked in that first film even
his character kind of looks like that
Android but moving forward to Rhodey
saying his password for war machine or
machine 68 1968 is actually the year
that he was born which is pretty fun I
also just want to give a shout out to
that awesome fight where Tony's just
wearing a boot and a glove from the Iron
Man suit one of my favorites and when
one of the aim agents drops his gun and
says hey man I just work here these guys
are crazy
essentially one of Robert Downey junior
stunt choreographers who worked with him
on Sherlock Holmes and the other Iron
Man films also worth mentioning that
their amazing sequence when Iron Man's
rescuing people as they're falling out
of a plane they shot that many times
using actual skydivers so that's legit
and finally guys don't worry I didn't
miss it
Stanley gets this awesome cameo right
here as a judge for a beauty pageant
take back awesome it kind of creepy but
hey it's in the movie those are all the
Easter eggs and hidden references I was
able to find let me know which ones were
your favorite or if I missed some let me
know in the comments down below or on
twitter at only stupid answers you have
to bounce from stupid but guys make sure
you like this video comment down below
share it with your friends who love
Marvel films and subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns there's so
many make sure you tune in as well to
new rockstars news I'm on that panel
show it's a whole bunch of fun I'm Sam
basher and I'll see you next time